والان بالعوده الى القاره الاوروبيه
والسؤال عن انعكاس الحرب في اوكرانيا على
ميزانيات الدفاع هناك الى مستويات بلغت
احيانا تغيير بعض هذه الدول عقيدتها
العسكريه وفقا لمعهد مكانزي فانه لو لم
تندلع الحرب لكانت نفقات دول حلف النيتو
اضافه الى السويد وفنلندا واستراليا
سترتفع من
296 مليار دولار لعام 2021 الى
337 مليار دولار لعام
2006 اي بزياده لا تتجاوز 14% لكن اندلاع
الحرب غير الكثير ورفع التوقعات نحن
وزياده النسبه للفتره ذاتها الى 53%
وباللغه النقديه هذا يعني اربعه
453 مليار دولار سنويا في اوروبا ستكون
اعلى زياده للانفاق الرقم هو نصف تريليون
دولار سنويا بحلول عام
وفي الامثله الاوروبيه المانيا
بميزانيه بلغت 100 مليار دولار فرنسا
ميزانيه بلغت 400 مليار دولار اذا ارقام
مهوله
هذا الارتفاع كان مرتبطا بالحرب في
اوكرانيا
فكيف كان دعم دول النيتو لاوكرانيا
قدمت الولايات المتحده
319 مليون يورو اي ما يعادل
16% من ميزانيه النيتو وقدمت المانيا
المبلغ نفسه
او ما تاتي بريطانيا التي قدمت
201 مليون يورو اي ما يعادل اكثر من 11%
من ميزانيه النيتو للعام الجاري
بلغ ما تعهدت به فرنسا مثلا مئتين وخمسه
وخمسه ملايين يورو اي اكثر من عشره في
المئه من ميزانيه الحلف ثم تاتي ايطاليا
ايطاليا قدمت مئه واثنين وسبعين مليون
يورو اي ما يقدر باكثر من ثمانيه في المئه
من ميزانيه النيتو للعام الحالي
اذا زيادات فعلا لافته وكبيره جدا ومعنى
لمناقشتها من باري في جنوب ايطاليا
الجنرال بس كوالي
رئيس مرصد يورسبيس للامن والقائد السابق
للقوات الجويه الايطاليه اهلا وسهلا بك في
الحصاد
كما ذكرنا ارقام كبيره نسب فاقت كل
التوقعات الى اي حد
سيتغير مستقبل اوروبا على ضوء هذه الارقام
هذا مسائكم جميعا اولا اعتقد ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبعد عام من من هذه الحرب قد
وصل الى بعض النقاط
الجيده اولا ينبغي الاشاره الى ان
البوصله الاستراتيجيه قد تمت الموافقه
عليها
في مارس 2022
وما هو اكثر من ذلك هناك زياده في وتيره
التكامل عمليه التكامل الاوروبي والفضل
يعود في ذلك الى اثار وافرازات هذه الحرب
فقط تم تمرير
عدد من
الخطوات والاجراءات التي لم تكن متوقعه من
من جانب الدول الاوروبيه وتم تاسيس ايضا
مبادئ
لتقديمي معدات عسكريه ومعدات وسلاح من
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اوكرانيا وعلاوه على
ذلك ايضا
فيما يتعلق
بالمساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا هي ايضا
تتمخضت عن هذه
الخطوات ليس في زياده انفاق بل زياده
المساعد هذا ما تم التوصل ولكن هو السؤال
الجوهري هنا على حساب ماذا يعني على حساب
التعليم على حساب الضمان الاجتماعي على
حساب القطاع الصحي يعني نرى كثير من
الاحتجاجات والاضرابات في دول اوروبيه
مختلفه الى متى تستطيع ان تصمد
وتغفر لحكوماتها هذا هذه الزياده في
الانفاق العسكري
نعم هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه المشكله هنا
تكمن في انه ما هو التالي
وماذا سيكون المستقبل للاتحاد الاوروبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يريد حربا على ارضه
نحن قد سبق لنا وان عانينا من حربين
عظميين الحرب العالميه الاولى والحرب
العالميه الثانيه ولا نريد حربا اخرى في
هذه المنطقه لهذا السبب نحن نزود
الاوكرانيين بهذه
المعدات لاننا عندما بدانا بهذه الحرب كان
الغرض هو استعاده السلام كما هو الحال
دائما لكن الحرب طالت يعني ربما كان الغرض
ان يتم الامر بسرعه لم يحصل
الى متى تستطيع هذه الدول الاوروبيه ان
تصمد
اعتقدوا ان وحده الموقف للبلدان الاوروبيه
قويه اليوم
وسنرى في المستقبل ماذا سيحدث لكن دعوني
اقول ان الاقتصاد
بدا يعاني وايضا اراده البلدان الكبرى ما
زال يصير نحو دعم اوكرانيا لكسب الحرب هذا
ما عزمت عليه الغالبيه من البلدان
الاوروبيه طبعا هناك بلدان مثل هنغاريا
التي تظهر
بوادر يمكن ان نسميها عدم رضا لكن
هذا فقط اعراب عن عدم رضا ليس الا بس
كوالي
رئيس مرصد يوسفيس للامن والقائد السابق
للقوات الجويه الايطاليه شكرا جزيلا لك